I'm uh 24 I'm currently debt free um I
make $80,000 a year I am currently
maxing out my 401k and
Ira I want to buy a car that cost
$30,000 um however I'm I don't want to
get rid of my current car it would just
be a you know a play car it's it's a
sports car I have 30,000 in cash that
I'm prepared to pay for this car I'm not
sure if it's better to put this in a
different sort of Investment Portfolio
or if it would be okay
you know to to splurge and buy this car
oh I see I thought you were calling the
car an investment my face was turning
inside out okay I love cars but the
stupid things go down in value Like a
Rock that's where Chevy got that like a
rock okay they go down in value if
you're going to build wealth you have to
keep as small an amount in as possible
going into things that go down in value